buenas noches
les quiero contar una historia durante
más de 13 años yo tuve un problema iba
todos los días a trabajar sin ganas como
desmotivado sentía esa pesadez cada día
que tenía que ir a trabajar sentir es
alivio los fines de semana
los trabajos no me duraban mucho tiempo
todo el que me conoce sabe esto me
llegaban a augurar el que me duró más
tres años
algunas veces llega a cambiarme al mes y
de haberme cambiado de trabajo esto hizo
que en estos 13 años pasear por medio
montevideo por más de 10 empresas
entonces llegó un momento que dije a
carácter y me parece que soy yo
este
había algo que tenía que cambiar no
quería seguir haciendo lo mismo no
quería que me siguiera pasando lo mismo
entonces reflexionando dije esto que
está tan de moda emprender yo quiero
emprender en realidad no estaba seguro
que quería emprender lo que sí quería
era cambiar la situación hasta que tenía
entonces digo bueno es genial quiero
emprender pero entonces qué hago
cómo hago qué voy a emprender en qué
capaz que algunos de ustedes que
estuvieron es que esta misma situación
la sensación que sienten es como estar
al borde de un abismo siente como un
frío un miedo que los paraliza que no
tienen ni de paraná arrancar
entonces yo tengo un montón de miedos en
mi cabeza que daban vueltas y vueltas
los vídeos que yo tenía ustedes ven en
pantalla tenía miedo que no quería
fracasar
se me ocurrían ideas de negocio pero
pensaba que esas ideas no lo
suficientemente buenas
pensaba que era muy difícil ser
emprendedor
y también pensado que era muy grande el
riesgo
no les suena seguramente que si alguno
de ustedes se encontró en esta situación
alguna de estas sillas el paso por la
cabeza
bueno no quiero fracasar porque le
tenemos miedo al fracaso le tenemos
miedo al fracaso porque lamentablemente
tenemos muy arraigado el concepto de
condenar de señalar con el dedo a la
persona que fracasa un emprendimiento
dígame si no es así lo que a veces nos
reímos la espalda de la gente diciendo
miren al igual que le fue más lenta el
emprendimiento
acá yo lo que descubrí es que tenemos
que importar
cultura de por ejemplo eeuu o europa
donde ellos el fracaso lo consideran
como algo positivo miren que lo conozco
encierra el fracaso como algo positivo y
porque consideran el fracaso como algo
positivo porque saben que el fracaso
desde donde se aprende cuando las cosas
van bien nosotros no aprendemos mucho
nosotros realmente aprendemos cuando nos
chocamos con la realidad y cuando nos va
mal en ese momento es cuando realmente
aprendemos
entonces cuando el día que nosotros
aprendamos a valorar los fracasos es
cuando le vamos a perder el miedo a
fracasar y eso es algo que yo descubrí
en este camino
para mí fracasar es no intentar es
quedarse de brazos cruzados
para mí tener éxito es ir de fracaso en
fracaso sin darse por vencido
el que sea por vencido desde que fracasa
entonces la próxima vez que ustedes
piensen y se les venga la idea la cabeza
de que no quiero fracasar
yo les pido que aprendamos a valorar los
fracasos como algo constructivo
otro miedo que tenía como recién les
decía era que esta idea capaz que no es
muy buena se me venían ideas de negocio
de emprendimiento y yo pensaba no
prestaría capas que no es
suficientemente buena me voy a quedar
acá de brazos cruzados esperando que se
me ilumine la lamparita y vaya inventé
el próximo iphone o la descubra algún
invento que va a cambiar el mundo
bueno otra cosa que descubrí en estos
años es que las ideas no valen nada lo
que vales como una ejecutas las ideas
una idea en la cabeza de una persona no
vale nada le voy a poner un ejemplo bien
sencillo como para que todos podamos
entender
mcdonnell no cuando ustedes conocen
gente que cocina bien y que seguramente
puede hacer una hamburguesa más rica que
la que pueden encontrar más jóvenes
seguramente en una cantidad ahora esas
personas les están haciendo la
competencia más canal yo creo que no
entienden lo que les digo la idea de más
gana se defenderá de hamburguesas pero
sin embargo el éxito de mcdonald se
sustenta en el sistema que crea un
alrededor de la idea de vender
hamburguesas y eso es lo que hace que
ellos hoy tengan un éxito internacional
entonces las ideas en la cabeza no valen
nada entonces como decías no vale nada
no nos quedemos tratando de reinventar
la rueda o inventar la pólvora de vuelta
no tenemos que ser unos genios creativos
a la hora de innovar oa la hora de
emprender
le quiero poner un ejemplo que me
encantó que descubrí durante todo estos
años que es un ejemplo uruguayo de
muchachos llamado raffaela tijas es un
músico que se encuentra con esta
situación le quiere enseñar a tocar la
guitarra a su sobrina de 6 años entonces
se sienta con la sobrina le da la
guitarra convencional a que todos
conocemos y se da cuenta que es
imposible que la nena de 6 años aprenda
a tocar la guitarra de cero porque es
muy complicado por lo menos para ese
entonces que dice se se quedó de brazos
cruzados e dijo bueno no le voy a poder
enseñar toco la guitarra no tuvo un
momento de brillantes y lo que dijo fue
voy a simplificar la guitarra para que
sea más fácil es poder enseñar a los
hijos a los niños y que hizo crea una
guitarra de tres cuerdas
nada más sencillo que eso viernes y una
vez que lo piensan así no dicen bueno
bueno está bien pero se le ocurrió a él
y el éxito que tuvo esto no tiene
precedentes se vende en todo el mundo se
vende en más de 30 países no dan abasto
a producir se venden los supermercados
eeuu como pan caliente
no sé si mi canal de la foto ron wood
guitarrista de los rolling son no es
publicidad de esto
ron wood por su propia cuenta subió a
instagram un video de cuando me enseñaba
a tocar a sus hijas cuando enseñado toco
la guitarra y adivinen que estaba usando
la guitarra de tres cuerdas de rafa que
les dije
a mí que me gustaba en términos
futbolísticos para mí estadio como salía
campeón del mundo
más esto no se puede ver
entonces a la hora de emprender lo que
tenemos que buscar es tratar de resolver
problemas sencillos problemas cotidianos
problemas que nos pasan a nosotros todos
los días a nosotros a nuestros hijos a
nuestros padres nuestros abuelos no
tratemos de reinventar la rueda no
pensemos en cosas demasiado rebuscadas
incluso a la hora de innovar se puede
también adaptar y adaptar es sinónimo de
copiar mucha gente piensa que copiar
para emprender está mal y está lleno de
emprendimientos que lo que haces es lo
que hacen es copiar lo que hacen en otro
lado y no hay nada de malo en eso por
ejemplo intentar adaptar localmente algo
que ustedes vieron en un montevideo o
que vieron en otro país o en otra ciudad
del interior y vienen y lo intentan
hacer alcanza jose está lleno de
productos y servicios que se hacen en
otro lado que acá no hay y bueno pero
por qué no traemos algo eso para acá y
vemos si funciona o no no se sientan
frustrados si no tienen una idea para
para emprender pueden copiar no está mal
y para hacer un poco más énfasis sobre
la idea para mí mucho más importante que
la idea es la pasión que nosotros le
podemos poner a lo que hacemos cuando
uno trabaja con pasión y hace lo que le
gusta las horas pasan volando no nos
damos cuenta de todo el tiempo que
estuvimos trabajando y estamos dispuesto
a hacer un esfuerzo muchísimo mayor
que cuando estamos haciendo algo que no
nos gusta entonces la próxima vez que
usted les venga ese miedo de decir no
pero esta idea no es suficientemente
buena yo lo que les recomiendo es que
hay que buscar proyectos lo que nos
apasione trabajar
también otro miedo que yo tenía era es
muy difícil ser emprendedor no sé si voy
a poder hacerlo
y obviamente es verdad es muy difícil
ser emprendedor pero otra cosa que
descubrí también en este camino es que
cualquiera puede ser emprendedor y
cuando digo cualquier es cualquier
persona que así lo quiera puede ser
emprendedor
para encontrar un montón de dificultades
y claramente no es fácil nadie dice que
fácil va a pensar que va todo bien y de
repente se choca con algo y se tiene que
poner el traje de bombero y salir a
pagar incendio por todos lados y eso les
va a pasar también les va a pasar que
sienten que no tienen tiempo o que no
sobre todo en los inicios le van a tener
que dedicar mucho más tiempo del que
ustedes pensaban que llevaba
pero es todo cuestión de prioridades si
uno quiere realmente algo va a ordenar
su vida para poder hacerse tiempo para
lo que realmente quiere hacer y también
se va a encontrar con mucha gente que
les va a decir no pero ustedes están
locos esa idea que me decís no tiene ni
pies ni cabeza eso no va a funcionar
solo a vos y te ocurre eso y eso ya lo
probaron no funciona pero bueno hay
lamentablemente oídos sordos porque eso
no son más que excusas para no llevar
adelante un proyecto si nosotros estamos
convencidos de que lo vamos a hacer con
pasión todo lo demás no importa
otra cosa que podemos hacer dado que es
difícil emprender y buscar ayuda tenemos
que reconocer que estamos ante la
necesidad de buscar ayuda hay un montón
de cosas que podemos hacer por ejemplo
están los libros había un libro que me
sirvió mucho es ese que está la portada
y que se llama el método línea startup
que yo lo apliqué en un emprendimiento y
me sirvió mucho no quiere decir que le
vaya a servir a todo el mundo acá no hay
manuales no hay recetas a uno le puede
servir una cosa a otro le puede servir
otra lo que sí es hay un montón de
material para que la gente pueda
estudiar investigar y por supuesto
internet hoy se sabe que con un par de
clics podemos acceder a información y
averiguar sobre lo que nosotros queremos
hacer y saber cómo se hizo en otro lado
o tomar consejos de la gente que ya pasó
por lo mismo también están las
incubadoras de negocios u otro tipo de
proyectos que son para apoyar a los
emprendimientos en los primeros años de
vida y también está el viejo y querido
pedir consejo a mí esto fue algo que me
sirvió mucho pedir consejo piden consejo
algún amigo
algún familiar algún conocido que haya
emprendido que le haya ido bien y que le
haya ido mal acuérdense que al que le
fue mal seguramente capaz que ha
aprendido mucho
que le fue bien entonces piden consejos
de los soldados
y mientras están juntando toda esta
información
hay que evitar caer en lo que se llama
la parálisis del análisis que es la
parálisis del análisis bueno recibí le
decía lea libros busque en internet
hablen con amigos
bueno ahí va a llegar un momento que la
cabeza les va a explotar está porque van
a tener tanta información
y un amigo les dijo hagan esto y el otro
amigo le dijo no no eso no lo haga
entonces al final ese frío y ese miedo
que tenía en el principio vas a pasar un
momento que van a sentir que es peor
entonces en ese momento cuando se vea en
esa situación yo lo que les recomiendo
lo que aprendí que hay que hacer es
pasar a la acción uno haciendo aprende
500 veces más que leyendo con la teoría
lo que uno aprende haciendo no se
compara con lo que uno leyó o estudió
entonces
cuando se les venga el miedo de que
piense que es muy difícil entender
emprender yo les recomiendo que aprendan
haciendo
y la última y del último miedo que yo
tenía era que el riesgo de emprender es
muy grande
y vaya que sigan el riesgo de emprender
claro que es grande no hay que minimizar
que emprender tiene sus riesgos
estadísticamente décadas y hoy se
crearán 100 empresas dentro de tres años
sólo van a quedar vivas diez empresas
eso quiere decir que hay 90 empresas que
quedaron por el camino es una cifra muy
grande y todos la sabemos entonces todos
tenemos sabemos internamente de que el
riesgo de emprender es muy grande
pero ya vimos que hay montón de
herramientas que nos pueden ayudar pero
ahora yo les pregunto una cosa está bien
el riesgo emprender es grande pero no es
grande también el riesgo de pasarse toda
una vida trabajando en algo que no les
guste de ir desmotivados todos los días
a trabajar debe encontrar algo que
realmente les apasione se piensa en si
eso no es muy riesgoso también no les ha
pasado que cuando era una persona que
ustedes ven que trabajan en algo que es
vocacional para esa persona como que
emana un brillo un aura una energía
positiva y ustedes dicen pucha pero yo
quiero eso para mí bueno a mí me pasó
esto yo lo que les recomiendo es que en
vez de quedarse en vez de quedarse
sentado sin hacer nada salgan y
construyan esa vida para ustedes porque
nadie los va a ser para ustedes sí no
entonces la siguiente vez que piensen
que es muy difícil el riesgo de
emprender
suele dijo que piensan que si no el
riesgo de no emprender no puede ser
mayor
bueno entonces son por suerte siempre
tuve claro que yo no quería correr ese
riesgo de no emprender porque el largo
plazo yo no me quería quedar con la
intriga de sí
podría ser un emprendedor entonces me
decidí tome impulso y me largué por
cuenta propia y tuve seis o siete
proyectos en los cuales lamentablemente
tuvo que dejar por el camino porque me
fueron las cosas mal pero aprendí un
montón de cada proyecto ido aprendiendo
un poco más y por suerte hoy puedo decir
que tengo un emprendimiento que es la
base de mi sustento económico y ojo que
es ese ingreso que yo tengo del
emprendimiento debe ser menos de la
mitad del ingreso que yo tenía hace
cuatro años cuando dejé mi último
trabajo como empleado pero saben que no
me importa y porque no me importa porque
encontré una motivación para trabajar
todos los días encontré trabajar en algo
de una pasión es
encontré la manera de hacer tiempo a
hacerme tiempo para hacer cosas que
quería hacer siempre y que no tenía
tiempo y lo más importante
encontré tiempo para estar con mi
familia y para poder disfrutar de la
crianza de mis hijos de una manera que
no hubiera soñado nunca
y entonces hoy en definitiva soy 10
veces más feliz de que cuando solo tenía
un ingreso mayor y lo que descubrí que
eso no tiene precio y no lo cambio por
nada del mundo
para mí el éxito no se mide por quién
tiene más o por quién gana más el éxito
solo amigo por esa capacidad que tenemos
los seres humanos de poder crear y
diseñar la vida que queremos vivir
y de poder vivir el día a día como si
fuera el último y poder vivirlo con
ganas y con determinación porque al
final de cuentas como dicen por ahí el
camino es la recompensa muchas gracias